this show is brought to you by hello
tushy the days are back
the church of what's happening now is
proud to introduce you to hellotushy
hellotushy.com
makes portable devices that spray your
butt clean with water it's it's it's
it's like a power washer it's it's the
most amazing thing i've had in my
bathroom i would i would i would give up
my shower before i gave up my hello
tushy i mean you could wash your feet
you could hold your dick hole and you're
back in action you could get a little
water running through your face and
there you are like a [ __ ] savage
you know what i'm saying so forget about
living in a hotel no more with donna
hellotushy.com
washes your muffler your scrotum your
helmet the back of your thighs just in
case you got some monkey grease back
there or you left some vaseline from two
weeks ago
and that's it go to hellotushy.com what
do they get lee if you go to
hellotushy.com and enter promo code
church you're going to get 10 off of
your order honestly get it get it for
your friends get it for your family the
[ __ ] holidays every day
nobody
nobody has a [ __ ] bidet but everybody
needs one it's like a tie
it's like handcuffs you know what i'm
saying nobody needs them nobody will
come in handy
you get 10 off bam wow on it talk to me
if you go to honest.com and use codeword
church you're going to get 10 off of
your order of all of their amazing
optimization tremendous alpha brain new
mood shroom tech shroom tech sport
shroom tech immune i can't tell you all
the great things you get a little older
you're feeling under the weather you
can't remember where you put your
[ __ ] car keys alpha brain is for you
and they got 100 100 money back
guarantee go to honor.com right now on
the way out enter promo code church to
get 10 off boom kick this [ __ ]
horsely
and then
just go to
cso.com it was de-escalating right there
we were we were at a peak and then it
dipped a little bit
oh [ __ ]
it's that type of day here at the church
a little nucleus i heard it on a
studio 54 radio on the way here you got
to kick it up leo i'm gonna [ __ ] i
want to be a deaf all my life let's do
this [ __ ]
wow
it's gonna be that type of show ladies
and gentlemen
it's a good one today we ain't [ __ ]
around oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
mix it spank that ass oh [ __ ] here it is
here it comes it's going to rub up
against your little muffler right now
delta 88 yeah this is it this is this is
summer of [ __ ] 84. yeah breakdancing
with the pledge great busting the
cardboard out
breaking down boxes so you can dance on
the corner and battle people
b boys
the weird thing is i like to beat from
this jam but the thing i like them is
the guys rap kick it lead kick it kick
king elite all the way blow up the
[ __ ] speakers lee blow it
there you go
to church what's happening now
[ __ ] kick don't touch that
controlling [ __ ] over this [ __ ] sound
what
come on
oh [ __ ]
here we go here we go
take that quite luck stuff here we go
here we go oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it's the bridge
oh [ __ ]
now you're going into the darkness of
the jam here we go
that [ __ ] oh my god synthesizer just
kicked him this does not even this does
not end
i could close my eyes and take myself
back to a dance floor and you're losing
it you got a gorilla biscuit in here
[ __ ] not even just dancing with some hot
chicken [ __ ] she's hipping up on you
what are you wearing you're rubbing your
helmet on their [ __ ] the side of
their hip and [ __ ] but most importantly
man you're really [ __ ] digging the
music yeah and then i went to see him
live and they blew my mind right here
watch this rap
he says one line at the end that my head
always blows up
and i knew one day i would rock the
nation so i made up my mind what
what
what ghetto [ __ ] crazy man sells
these words
listen to this [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] light that joint
up i'm telling you right now listen to
this [ __ ]
see
oh [ __ ]
it don't and you haven't heard the
weight of the word [ __ ] one time
there was respect you understand
listen to this [ __ ]
oh it has a stop
this is like dave david gilmour's guitar
dogs it don't stop coming at you
get down
then the other guy jumps in the head
[ __ ] yam goes really
here we go
it's what sept races from the rest dudes
i'm telling you right now he's throwing
it
superman
he's throwing superman in the mix what
black dude shows up with superman this
is what i'm talking about people in 84
84 who shows up for superman
i'm fast
around the world without missing a beat
it's too [ __ ] good too good oh she's
a jam man this is too [ __ ] good
people at home like what the [ __ ] has he
got me listening to oh this listen [ __ ]
right let your shoes go
your foot's tapping right now this is a
jam and a half though
this go kryptonite
don't stop don't stop don't stop
so i can't do it wrong here we go right
here
jam mommy
it's too much i'm not going to do a bomb
at the valley
here we go here's the head movie
here we do here we go
jam on
how bad is this [ __ ]
remember cruising in this
cruiser
i remember snorting three eight balls
for this [ __ ] jam i couldn't wait for
my head to blow up kick this kick this
mute take this [ __ ] me away welcome
to the church what's happening now my
main goomba lisayet my main [ __ ]
representing chicago today from the
[ __ ] heart of chicago not one of
these okie doke [ __ ] with a
blue hat on with a seal walking around
today because i bet if you go to [ __ ]
starbucks you're going to see all the
[ __ ] fair-weathered [ __ ] jerkballs
that don't do dick about dick they just
show up they don't know nothing
congratulations thanks brother
congratulations to a [ __ ] city that
deserves it
with all their [ __ ] i mean you know
just just
when you go there it's a pleasure to go
to that [ __ ] city and they even talk
[ __ ] about the airport i don't give a
[ __ ]
sometimes it's worth the walk yeah yeah
you're a fat [ __ ] you need to [ __ ]
walk walk your [ __ ] yeah i got a little
electric sidewalk there oh my god don't
let your sidewalk don't do dick for
nobody by the time you get there isis
will show up on the other side and shoot
you with a [ __ ] gun
and he'll tell you about that though
when you booked a ticket jesus that
[ __ ] walk is brutal you don't watch
electric sidewalks huh you don't do
electric sidewalks look i take
everything that can help me out when
you're in a rush i like to sidewalk
don't do memphis
it feels like you're going back in time
when you land in ohio that's how slow
you're going it's all every man for
himself dude i'm a chubby guy i will sit
on that electric sidewalk and not move
not in chicago
this is all straight up they will
[ __ ] straight on you right in the
neck and [ __ ] with their luggage and not
give a frenchman's [ __ ]
when you're in o'hare you got to walk
that [ __ ] electric thing like it's
the last walk of your life yeah you got
a jacket and don't fly and don't connect
in detroit when you got to walk under
the airport at six in the morning at the
blue lights and [ __ ] and you think
you're in the twilight zone people have
no idea that i fly in the middle of the
night that's like vampire [ __ ]
we've seen each other a couple of times
on flights in vegas right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that was fun i fart everybody smells in
the back
they don't even have [ __ ] recruitment
back there they don't even
every every time you go on southwest
that's every man for they give you a
drink and a [ __ ] thing of the flu but
south and west ain't bad
it just gets you there in two hours like
when you get on southwest you know
you're gonna get there yeah like it's
like your drunk uncle he's around yeah
he'll give you another one
yeah you know but i'm not driving lax to
take some [ __ ] virgin who gives a
[ __ ] no southwest is southwest is okay
the one though a terrible one is spirit
i i almost looked into flying that in a
couple weeks and i couldn't bear it in
the frontier
they don't even the insurance company
just hangs up on you
because they know it's a loser
you see everyone in spirit and frontier
in their seats with floaties on just in
case of [ __ ] goatees
they got rosary beads in their [ __ ]
hands and [ __ ]
it's like you you know you know you want
a frontier lost my luggage they found it
two countries away you know what i said
just leave it there there was nothing in
there i went on frontier that was
horrible with a buddy pass
it was one of the worst flying
experiences of my life first we gotta
land in denver they got a big electric
sidewalk that's another airport you
don't want to connect
uh
where else did i and the spirit spirit
spirit is the southwest of the south i
guess
uh okay so what you do is let's say you
got to go from atlanta
to orlando atlanta to chicago they're
not bad they got xm radio so you could
listen to the disco classics gotcha
whatever the [ __ ] you rent the rock
classic
like i said listen the whole experience
of flying has really changed in this
country last 20 years
i look at it as a part of people take
their [ __ ] shoes and socks off and
put them on
people's chairs or on the armrest they
put their bare [ __ ] hoofs
on i see that
it's unbelievable can you imagine i just
look up saying what prayer for them
planet you got to live on
to put your foot that close to another
like unwelcomed
on i mean that is if you put your feet
next to me i gotta say something to you
it's gonna be a [ __ ] problem on the
flight yeah you know uh
in those middle aisles that's where
immigration goes all the time those
people who don't fly a lot and they they
act
it's horrible listen when i see a guy
with his feet out
i say two prayers once for the plane to
go down and then i retract it and i say
i hope he gets diabetics in his feet
those sticky pringles and [ __ ] they're
not working you can't i'm not talking
about flying in that way it's even on
the other aspect how they treat the
consumer yeah they really don't give a
[ __ ] they don't give you updates when
you're there you don't know
what misery is to you stuck in an
airport and for you people right now
listen to me i know i know
it might be the last time you see
grandma listen to me
listen to me
ten more days ain't gonna kill grandma
okay you get a plane ticket on january
4th you're living like a doctor you come
back there's no lines you got no [ __ ]
drama everybody wants to fly in
christmas every time i tell you right
now you want to go fly on christmas time
and i'm not talking about the people who
leave on the 9th they're kind of
intelligent they're kind of intelligent
there's some people leave on the ninth
and make three weeks of it but not
everybody's in that financial gain that
you could take off [ __ ] three weeks
then you just gotta take down a good
score wherever you're going yeah you
gotta make moves where you're going to
make up for the week you had to lose
something warm me up i'll hook you up
with [ __ ] 22 pounds of edibles
by the time you get there even if you
don't get high your whole [ __ ] family
will be hot
every time we travel you say i have to
like mule something oh we'll get them
the last time i had them going to the
airport
the last time i started here i gave him
an edible one that night after we got
off the air i go listen tomorrow there's
a dude because we're going to [ __ ]
texas i got some guys on me at the
airport i set it all up
he said give me 30 large
on the way down the envelope you drop it
off over there just drop off your
suitcase don't give me 30
he started with the questions while
watching the emblem
you're concerned well you don't eat
first of all you need a sturdy [ __ ]
watch it's going to start at 30 large it
started at like 10 and every time every
time that's a good number yeah that's a
good it's a good number but not for
federal prison and intends a round
number do you think i would [ __ ] do
anything to you to keep you in the
federal prison yeah
if you mule something it's because it's
taken care of from a to [ __ ] z can i
can i just say something here on your
behalf
do you think let's hypothetically say
you got caught right yeah and you go to
federal prison okay and you get brutally
[ __ ] raped in the shower he will not
get raped no but just hype
hypothetically he's going to have a
mission hypothetically no no i know but
but thank god i'm on an edibles right
now i'd be having a panic attack but
see how nervous and nerve-wracking that
would be but what happened when you got
to your bunk and there's a little card
from uncle joe that's right it's saying
hey thank you there's a bidet waiting
for you at home hellotushie.com
listen to me
i would 10 is a great number that's a
that's a hot rock for a move even when i
was doing that flight [ __ ] i knew i had
it covered 90 percent
because the most important coverage you
need is in your mind do you know that
yeah be centered you know people always
say to me well joey you fly with weed no
but if i did there's times i have a bag
listen last time somebody gave me wax in
new york at caroline's or whatever it
was uh gotham i performed at gotham's
every year and i was at gotham somebody
gave me a wax pen with a [ __ ] chunk
of wax
and i had my t-shirts my buddy was
selling me t-shirts and i brought the
little bag i got a little luggage bag
for like when i go to vegas for two days
or
phoenix one of these small two night
gigs this is the move merch
this was old merch this is a couple
years ago two years ago and some guy put
it in and i took it and put it in the
side zipper
only times i flew with that little
[ __ ] bag i just forgot i forgot it
was in there yeah
do you have any [ __ ] idea how many
times like it was like a year later i
went in there and i go holy [ __ ]
i've been flying for a year with a
controlled substance you get caught in
an apple with weed
that's one thing
these [ __ ] idiots that fly with vapor
pens and waxes and [ __ ] that's a control
substance oh really yeah if they want to
be [ __ ] evil scumbags
at the end of the day yeah and then
they're gonna go in your luggage and
they're gonna find three more of those
tubes
and that's two years of peace you know
you have to get an attorney
that's mandatory sentencing round ish
you never know yeah it depends on what
movie you never [ __ ] know yeah you
never know you never know [ __ ] you never
know what they're [ __ ] thinking
that's why i'm really [ __ ] waxed i've
been out of the game from wax is this
[ __ ] thing they make and you have to
get a nail made out of metal and smoke
oh i think it's too much enough right
yeah it's too much drama funko i'm too
old my wife can't have a blowtorch at
the house okay i can't have a blowtorch
to get high
it don't mean that [ __ ] much to me
okay
i take two hits off a bong i'm fine
everybody's happy you know that's it i'm
goody goody why are you gonna complicate
you
we live in a society like i finally put
it together we don't complicate things
for ourselves i went trick-or-treating
and the kings of complication are
gentiles
nobody loves complications more than
gentiles now you're gonna understand
this story
i live on colfax
okay
between chandler
and uh
and deeper down there like by whatever
the [ __ ] it is
in my neighborhood there's a bunch of
kids and there was houses
we didn't have to walk on colfax
we meet the kids knock on the door my
little daughter sees him and goes daddy
i'm following the kids i mean that
little [ __ ] ran out of the [ __ ]
house i'm chasing her down the street
with my cowboy suit on
and she's a little girl you know she
wants to be with the rest of the kids
that's 15 kids yeah
and i can tell by each look at these
parents they're all mo mota you know two
of them in outfits
they were nice the english women were
nice but the people were just from the
neighborhood the white people they had
walking their dogs at the same time
tripping the kids you know it's always
got to be something yeah this is about
kids not the [ __ ] dogs take the dog
somewhere else yeah
so now we walk down and they're like so
what's our move
and then here these six parents
you know who actually live in the area
we get we're 50 yards from colfax now my
thinking is there's a driveway right
above kofax hood to the left and go on
to the next block and just zigzag the
blocks this way eliminate colfax yeah
all together busy especially it's 5 30.
yeah rush hour on a busy street no no no
they couldn't so we finally convinced
them to go down
colfax one block and make the left and
go into deep into the neighborhood so by
the next time i'm trying to tire out my
daughter
you know what i'm saying i'm trying to
tire her out she's been at school all
day halloween and [ __ ] in my mind this
trick-or-treat walk is to tie her out i
get to burn some calories
okay so we walked maybe two blocks
an hour later now it's pitch dark
guess what they want to do all the mom
says i just got a call
from one of my girlfriends and there's a
huge neighborhood with kids a
trick-or-treat it's over on best looking
whatever and she says it out loud so all
the kids hear it right right
and she goes that's [ __ ] party foul
number one like so where is this place
and she's like it's a cross colfax all
the way down by marie etc and it's
seven o'clock 7 30. i'm like i look at
my daughter i look at my wife and i go
terry i'm not going to colfax with this
child now this is when people get hit by
cars and says you don't know what
happened these are the type of events
that if you're not paying strict
attention yeah something happens to
somebody's child and you're a witness to
it and you go what the [ __ ] but in my
mind these people did not stop till they
went on colfax with these kids then they
wanted to stop traffic you know that
[ __ ] on the east listen my kids are
special everyone should stop saying that
this guy is drinking it he don't give
him yeah drive past something you go
that was a quick one i just missed that
by an inch yeah because this time your
mind doesn't allow to see you it's
halloween maybe you eat a pot cookie at
six o'clock who the [ __ ] knows yeah but
that means you gotta walk across colfax
and then walk back and you have some
dingbat parent who thinks putting their
hand down yeah no no no he's gonna stop
the [ __ ] car first when he did it the
cars just drove right past him and the
kids are three feet from him
i looked at my wife and i go you know
what
these are people who love
to complicate things
they can't sleep at night until
something you know for their friends to
impress somebody
there's 22 [ __ ] blocks of walking we
could have walked 22 blocks and not seen
colfax
but they weren't content
until and that's why sometimes when i
read stuff or see stuff on tv i'm not in
shock anymore now
this is what really burns me up in this
situation
excuse me i got seven i got left back in
the seventh grade
i dropped out of high school
you know i'm just a half a [ __ ] mutt
these people all college educated all
walk around like they're socrates that's
what really kills me yeah but when it
comes to simple life decisions
they're the dumbest [ __ ] people
they pay 250 grand to get dumber to get
dumber and then they move into a certain
area and they dummy up to that area and
they and they don't even see the right
they don't even see the fastball coming
down the [ __ ] pipe
it's a that's when i was walking on my
daughter mike saying why are you quiet
and i told her later i go it baffles me
i'm a street [ __ ] urchin
and i have more common sense than these
[ __ ] parents ever would have in their
[ __ ] lives
then they wonder
this doesn't end to one of these kids
ends in a morgue or something like that
and then they said they go what did i do
wrong you were really [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] i mean you just have to
so it's just and you know the kids are
going to grow up to be like the parents
like you ever go to when you drop your
daughter off at school the parents
are out of their [ __ ] minds cutting
everybody swearing
veering in how do you think those
[ __ ] kids are gonna grow up to be
i just drove by a school on sunset that
they had to literally put cones and
stuff in the middle of the road because
people were just dropping their kids off
at sunset they're like you can't it's we
you cannot drop or pick up your kids on
sunset boulevard and they had to
literally put a sign yeah and cones like
really they don't give a [ __ ] so
entitled so [ __ ] douchey
it's uh
it's really something weird to [ __ ]
see the reason why i wanted you on the
podcast is we had a conversation maybe
six weeks ago
and it was one of those conversations we
got off the phone with someone you know
that was [ __ ] up
that was a [ __ ] up conversation i mean
i wasn't i wasn't angry at you i just
learned something
like i had a conversation with you
make about your podcast and what was
going on in your life and you told me
you know what i'm just shutting the
lights on everything i made a decision i
just did my last podcast yesterday yeah
i wrapped up the office
and i i got up the phone i go this is a
guy that's doing great with a podcast
it's at the peak time you pull the
chapelle
yeah yeah i did
what happened
my schedule
this is gonna
so i'll give you a snapshot of what my
life was i was getting up at about
between 5 30 and 6 a.m and i was going
to bed between midnight and 1am
every day seven days a week so i was
working on a show for fox which is gonna
premiere
in march of 2017 called shots fired
amazing show
the most elevated storytelling i've ever
been a part of in my life right so i'm
challenged in that area i got this great
podcast going on i'm doing that once a
week drops monday
was having a little hard time getting
the caliber of guests that i wanted
right and so i was like do i just miss a
couple
and then if i miss a couple i'd see the
numbers go down and i'm like you know
this has to be i'm preaching hustling on
the podcast that's all my podcast is
about being passionate about your life
and hustling right so i'm like [ __ ] i
don't want to give anybody a a subpar
product so i'm like all right
then a guy says to me
i've been sober for 14 and a half years
married two kids
uh sober in an anonymous program that
part of the deal is you don't say the
name but a lot of that took a lot of my
time and that's a spiritual program
where you got to like lean into god a
little bit i was raised catholic i don't
necessarily
jive with that anymore so i don't know
who or what god is but i believe that
there is a god and i just throw
i throw my uh my spirit to that without
the risk of sounding [ __ ] cheesy to
that every day when i get up hey god
whoever you are whatever you do give me
the strength and the courage to be the
best man i can be in every area of my
life that's the general error right
so a guy who i work with says man you
just broke down your schedule and i'm
only giving you snapchat i'm also going
up and i'm doing stand up three to five
times a week i'm working on the show i'm
doing the podcast i'm writing a book i'm
developing two shows you and i met a
couple times about some things you had
going anybody that i truly respect and
you're a dad and i'm a dad i'm raising
two kids i mean it was so my guy says to
me this and it really floored me he goes
hey that's a that's a pretty busy
schedule and i go yeah he goes where's
god in that
and i just it it was like a stick in the
spokes that i had been so
intensely managing every moment in my
life trying to work it and ring success
out of it or wring happiness out of it
that i had a bit of moment of clarity
specifically with my podcast which i've
done for fun and for free for three plus
years
about how do you lead a good life what
does that mean and i've had academy
award winners championship fighters on
there nba champion coaches um gangsters
hit men you know wide gamut of people
and i just had this moment of commit
clarity that with the exception of my
family i'm letting everything go
i'm just gonna let it go and see what
happens so i let the podcast go i gave
up my office
i'm pitching two things next week two tv
shows i'm really excited about but
outside of that that actually came after
i let everything go
book no more stand up dates no more
storytelling dates no more public
speaking dates i do a lot of public
speaking on hustling
uh no acting stuff nothing and i just
got quiet
it just got quiet and i was left with my
family
and just being a [ __ ] man and and
making breakfast for my wife spending
time with the kids and i got rejuvenated
i got inspired and i felt i feel right
now
like i'm 19.
like it's not it's not i'm 42 now and i
should be peeking out as a writer and
good as a producer and then i'll you
know i'll take in the downtime i'll book
you know six weeks on the road
that may or may not happen but if it
does it's gonna be with new zeal and new
perspective and a new appreciation i set
everything down and i'd like to make an
announcement on the show man because
your show
uh with your help as well is one of the
shows that put my podcast on the map by
you guys being kind enough for having me
really you guys
uh the crab feast and burke chrysler's
podcast and uh jay moore those four
really drove people to my show uh but
i'm happy to announce that i'm going to
be starting my podcast up again oh are
you and i have not released that at all
were you bored without the podcast i
mean bored without it
i'll tell you i got you know by letting
everything go i wanted to see what came
back and what what what you know
not grading my uh success or or who i am
based on how i'm received by others but
the impact that that podcast was having
i think i underestimated it by how many
people were profoundly impacted by it by
the emails that i got when i said hey
guys i'm setting this down for a while i
got emails from all over the world that
were stunning and
i i don't think i could
after reading all of those not through
the podcast i think i have to because if
the whole point was to set everything
down and see what comes back you know no
comedy club called me and said hey we'd
like you you know come do a week in uh
you know tucson that didn't happen
who called were the networks hey what
shows are you thinking about developing
theaters called and said hey we would
like you to do an hour because you know
i do these storytelling things where i
just come out and
what i learned letting all of this stuff
go was
i've done stand up on nbc hbo i've done
the montreal i've done chicago comedy
festivals it never felt right to me
and i performed at the co all the best
clubs in the country i've performed in a
lot of them
i'm a storyteller man just like you i
need to tell stories i like telling them
in theaters and i've been trying to jam
it down a comedy club's throat and i
don't think it's fair to that audience
and i don't think it's fair to me and i
learned that by setting it all down
so i did a gig up in san francisco right
before i let everything go you know 100
seat black box theater jammed it sold it
out beautiful night did an hour great
stories some were sad some were funny
some were heartbreaking but it was
experience and and it wasn't like be
funny every three [ __ ] you know
everybody no no no and it's not my jam
now so i think not to say i'm better
than stand up but i've let that go yeah
i did it for 20 years when you tell the
story what people understand is when you
tell a story the humor will come out in
the store exactly naturally yeah if you
have to sit down and add those tags i
could see it while you're telling me the
story yeah that you've added this to the
[ __ ] story in a [ __ ] up way to
describe something i love a story when
it's just from the heart and the humor
will find itself in that [ __ ] story
exactly and i think
everyone like a comedian you know when
we go do i played clubs for 20 years
right and i've just set that down
invariably there will always be someone
that comes up and goes i think i'm funny
i could do this and that's great and you
tell them you know started open mics
whatever i think people feel the same
way about storytelling i could tell a
good story and maybe you can't but can
you captivate it you're a great
storyteller there's really like
20 of us out it's not a big there's a
lot of comedians but there's not a lot
of people that are like i tell stories
and they're like what's that going to be
like come [ __ ] see me come see me sit
down for an hour let me grab you and
then an hour later if you don't like it
i'll give you your money back
but we're not [ __ ] around we've lived
a life now i'm going to give it to you
i'm going to give you an hour snapshot
of a life that i've lived that would
have killed you 40 times over
and i'm gonna talk about what it's like
being on the other side of that
and really give you something that has
depth and weight and humor
and i only learned that by letting all
this stuff go it was profound man it's
been three months imagine i'm i have
that schedule and i go to three months
of radio silence
and it's been the most beautiful
invigorating
thing listen guys you need that we've
been [ __ ] banging it for years
and it's nice to take a break you know
here's the thing that
i deal with a lot of podcast people a
lot of podcast people hit me with emails
and questions
and i think
that a podcast is like stand up
just do it
just do it and the more you do it it
takes you somewhere and what your your
show theme will come out yeah and then
eventually you know i had a friend that
contacted me recently because i've been
doing my podcast for a year and a half
and nobody's coming to my comedy shows
if that's why you did the podcast then a
shame on you yeah it's an hour and a
half yeah it's an hour advertisement for
your shows i want there's no
so you could spill your heart out there
talk about your views on what's going on
in a funny way or in a sad way or in a
depressing way a real way and let in a
real way and let that don't don't
go with the status quo and just chime in
to their [ __ ] uh to fuel that you
know what i'm saying
it's not worth it a real one where you
come on there and you have your your
friends come in people that you know you
and tell different stories because they
really want to get to know you before
they can get to know your point of view
they need to know you this is a lot of
[ __ ] work
you have the people that get into it and
think ah
i'm just gonna talk [ __ ] for an hour
these guys just talk [ __ ] for an hour
well shame on you yeah it's like
everything else that you tried in your
life there's always a motive there
shouldn't be a motive
this shouldn't be a [ __ ] motive man
and i got to tell you in stand-up
in the 25 years i've maybe had like five
motives and if you know anything about
me there's always a [ __ ] motive you
know there's always a motive but what's
you know like oh my god i didn't know
tarantino was going to be here what a
surprise you know that type of [ __ ]
where a lot of comics are creepy like
yeah yeah i've only been creepy like
that like four or five [ __ ] times i
won't let myself you know everybody has
them uh everybody's an angle they're all
working in an angle
everybody has smoke and mirrors well my
podcast i'm gonna have dancers in the
room it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
what you have in the room if you sold
one in the [ __ ] room you know but i
applaud what you did because
listen man it takes it's it's very tough
for people to take an honest look at
themselves that's what i did yeah that's
bad that sums it up nothing gets my dick
harder when people look at me and go
again we always have people i'm older so
people call me up had a girl call me
about 18 months ago
not a bad looking girl i think she's
beautiful you know the way i look at it
there's no sexual advancements there
she's been banging it out with comedy
you know and
she left a good job and everything to
come out here and you know the pieces
aren't falling for her fast enough
yeah it's frustrating and i go you know
what do you want to do now don't get me
on the other side of coin
she's funny she's attractive but she's
not hilarious
and she doesn't have a hook and comedies
comedies
so you're competing with everyone that's
been in the game for 20 years that can
go out and murder
and you got to be loud and in that scene
now you got to be loud you have to
resonate somehow some way
so i said to you know and she asked me
to plant that am i funny
she goes because if i don't think i'm
funny anymore i'm gonna pack up and move
to milwaukee where the [ __ ] she's from
and i said to i go wouldn't be
right for me to tell you whether you're
funny enough that's not my business at
all i'm looking at the other side of the
coin i know that you're out five nights
a week
i know that you're right new material i
know you're hustling you know she's on
the [ __ ] send them packages to
managers and agents yeah yeah and this
is it this is this is i can't help you
and anything like that this is part of
the game yet put your dress on and do
your hair and put a ribbon in your hair
and try to figure out what managers
aren't involved in like
big buildings and [ __ ] that won't let
you in
and you just go and if they don't let
you in drop it off of them you're there
yeah at least they'll see it and they'll
open it up it's different
you got to be different that's the main
thing you know
so mick you uh when did you start
telling stories because i didn't know
you did comedy for 20 years like did you
start that sums up my [ __ ] comedy
career
well i i've known you since you've been
here in l.a yeah yeah well since i've
been here in l.a
no i mean i um
when i when i would do stand-up on tv
they'd say oh you have four and a half
minutes
and i go
i'd think what the [ __ ] can i do in four
and a half minutes and i'd feel so awful
because i couldn't serve that
opportunity you know like someone was
nice enough to go we like what you do
um will you do it on tv and i thought
that's when i really started to know
i tell stories like that's what i do so
when i would when i would headline a
show if i'm doing 45 or 50
i would have an arc to like priors early
work or bogosian or whoopi goldberg's
first special where she's doing telling
stories but doing characters in and out
of it louisiana's first special so it
was like a hybrid of a one-person show
and stand-up
but what i started to see that i enjoyed
most out of all of that was the
narrative as opposed to just banging on
the laughs and the people that stuck
with a 15-minute story
if i'm in a stand-up environment if i'm
doing a 15-minute setup
then subconsciously the payoff has to be
magnanimous to a 15-minute setup
but if you're seeing me in a theatrical
environment and i'm doing a story i can
get the same payoff because the audience
is listening to the story in a different
way it's weird if you if someone comes
out and goes now here is stand up they
some mode some switch goes off in their
brain where they're expecting to hear
the cadence of stand up but if you say
here comes the storyteller this person's
going to tell you stories for an hour
it's going to be new to a lot of people
right because they're like how's that
where i haven't even experienced
anything i know what the moth is i've
heard stories for five minutes or for
ten minutes how's that gonna work
and i go on and i'll do stories for 45
minutes or an hour
with twists and turns and an actual arc
it's an actual experience has something
you know it opens with me
looking at my kids and wondering whether
or not i'm going to give them the full
story about who i am and the stock that
they come from
when can i be honest with them about
that and then i go through my
experiences and then it ends at my
daughter's eighth grade birthday party
where she asked me the very simple
question have you ever done drugs yeah
it's not gonna work when you're selling
drinks on friday and saturday
it's
night
different it's a different mechanics
it's a whole different thing so i didn't
in in the
i think really answer the question that
you had was this when i was on shots
fired
it was uh gina prince bythewood and
reggie rock by the way they created the
show
they were committed to the best they
wanted the best out of everybody but
they did it in a very um motivating and
encouraging way but they're like
everything else can happen down here we
don't give a [ __ ] we work up here now
because we're smarter than everybody but
we have a very clear vision of what we
want to do how we want to execute it and
what we expect out of everybody
it's the first time in my career as a
writer that i've been around the best
who consistently do the best and it made
me ask the question if i'm doing all of
these things from six in the morning to
one in the morning what is my best does
my best even exist in there how can it
exist if i'm multitasking all of these
things and what would it look like to
experience my own personal best and what
is in in what area and it was too
confusing and that also motivated me to
go i got to let all of this go to see
what comes back and then individually
one thing at a time
commit a hundred and ten percent with
the risk of failing with the risk of
going wow i shouldn't be doing this
while maybe i'm not as good at this as i
thought i was
and really to the to the thing that i
dedicated three and a half years on my
podcast of like hustling and doing your
best i don't feel like i was doing it so
i had to learn a lot of diminishing
returns yeah okay it's a lot of
diminishing returns you got too many
[ __ ] hands and too many yet
so i do two podcasts a week and i go on
the [ __ ] road but they're all in the
same universe though those are those all
right you're a parent you know yeah and
when you go on stage at a comedy club
you could tell stories because i make a
living off terrible stories that's why i
said you're the exception but you have
to throw
excitement exactly you have to throw
excitement and nobody wants to hear
about their [ __ ] kids at a comedy
club and i'm saying very lightly do
people want to [ __ ] hear about
you know because somebody else i know is
having a problem with this he was like
i'm trying to tell a story and they're
not taking the ride and i thought about
in the car and i thought about and i go
you know what
10 30 on a saturday i want to hear about
[ __ ] kids
i don't
yeah i don't want to hear about [ __ ]
kids i've been drinking snorting blow i
want to hear about what [ __ ]
hillary's going to do or what this
[ __ ] is going to do and then you
could tell a story
that reflects about everything that's
going on yeah that's what works then you
got we we perform it we know how to
perform we know how to i was having a
great clubs were like whenever you want
to come back i was dissatisfied
i was just they were like this is great
people are coming out to see you and i
was like this is this isn't working for
me i think there's something better and
i have to maybe i'm wrong but i'm
committing to see if that's right if i
can perform it that way in an
environment where there are no drinks i
mean a lot of my audience is sober too
former savages you know that are just
raising kids that used to be lunatics
that are out trying to lead the best
life possible that they can i mean when
i played chicago man we sold the [ __ ]
out of that that was [ __ ] great
there's a great little theater shout out
to the wip theater and uh in edison park
on northwest highway those guys have
always been very kind to me they
actually just got their liquor license
but it was a little theater environment
and it you know the premise of this hour
i just spent the last year and a half
working on a new hour is that being an
adult is the most fraudulent thing i've
ever been a part of
that's the premise of the whole [ __ ]
new my new hour
is just you think when you're gonna when
you're a kid you grow up adults are
going to have all the answer nobody
knows a [ __ ] thing everybody's
looking at each other like do you know
do you know nobody knows nothing we're
not
[ __ ] kids i don't know nothing i
don't want to know nothing yeah
everybody i knew did drugs stole [ __ ]
fought and [ __ ] now they're telling
you gotta do your homework i gotta look
my son in his eye and go you gotta
[ __ ] study who the [ __ ] am i to say
that you know it's all fraudulent and
the and the feeling of [ __ ] shame and
compromise i got going well maybe he's
gonna hopefully have a totally different
life than i had and not have to
experience any of that [ __ ] i don't know
but i had to take him to the [ __ ]
graveyard and thomas grandmother was a
bisexual bank robbing [ __ ] prostitute
so you know sometimes life's
complicated it's not i live in a sham
too but you you gotta do what you gotta
do you make your [ __ ] i paid my debts
at society yeah i move on when she gets
to be old enough i'll sit it down tell
her what's happening with my own words
yes i'm not proud of it but i am
that's the complication that i'm
interested in joe that little thing that
you just said the bridge from from those
two situations
of now and when you have to have that
conversation to me
is fascinating fascinating i don't i
don't worry about it i don't feel guilty
about it
i do the best i can and i did something
with my life so yeah it's like everybody
else you said the 20s are for you to
[ __ ] up i [ __ ] up and i [ __ ] up some
of them in the 30s and i tell you what i
[ __ ] up two or three years of my 40s
so but
we cleaned that [ __ ] up yeah i was just
uh
i've always been amazed when people walk
away with something and put it into like
more of a micro thing you know
you like doing this theater thing listen
storytelling is a niche there's a big
business behind it there's a big
business behind it as you see we as
comedians we now have a storytelling
show
on one of the comedy essentials um
you know does that mean that's a staple
no somebody's gonna come up with a
better one yeah and put it on
hbo or you know it's out there will the
room start popping up for storytelling
[ __ ] yeah i know there's one the girl
that was on here
right right yeah yeah the girl was
susanna suzanna lee monday nights and
she packs them in down there yeah they
they change themes you know she has a
back room what's the name of that place
on vine next to the with pacquiao trains
there's a the three of clubs three clubs
yeah that's a nice venue yeah yeah they
do [ __ ] now storytelling's back
everybody i love it yeah i love to go
down there and feel free you know and
that's what i think freed my comedy the
first time i started telling stories in
99 in the belly room i was a different
monster because you're not going for the
laugh yeah and that teaches you a
different aspect of the game it teaches
you a little bit more control
it takes away that cheesy comedy feeling
that you have to deliver a joke every
three minutes and take your shirt off
and giggle yeah it took that away from
me it really did it was like oh my god
there's another aspect yes
now how to make it grow is uh
is the full between now here we are
[ __ ] what 16 years later
there's a story tell a show on i put out
five albums and just stories testicle
testing yes you know i mean
just for the priest that was like yeah
no that was the cd the comedy but this
is uh
i put out two dollar story telling cds
itunes
and i talked about the kidnapping i
talked about uh just doing coke
you know they were like two hours
weren't they leave we would [ __ ] go
for hours we'd go for [ __ ] hours edit
them and i i really believe in that
genre i really believe i think that the
next two or three years i know hbo will
come up with something because they'll
get celebrities you know they'll get uh
[ __ ] uh ray liotta to talk about his
time on goodfellas yeah i mean for me to
pitch a show would be like a tv show i
would pitch it about situations i would
get the three guys from the munsters
yeah to tell us a half hour of monster
stories the moth does that it's a theme
you show up yeah and they do a great job
i would have uh
uh you know uh what's the guy that's on
blue bloods now
tom selleck yeah to put go on with his
the black guy and the other dude and
talk about
uh
mackin p.i whatever that yeah you know
there's so many avenues for this you
could do this with musicians yeah
and get three band leaders together to
get def leppard talk about the 81 tool
with ma with motley crue whatever the
[ __ ] whoever they want with ac dcr judas
priest
there are so many different [ __ ]
venues i would love you know i read the
one arrow smith book and i was always
baffled on whether why they didn't do
more books like that
or that didn't become a tv show and it
was basically
steven tyler would tell a story about
the situation joe perrywood brad
whitford would and it's amazing drugs
what drugs does to your mind about
memories but it also each of them also
took a particular event from all of them
so something like that just have a
moderator eddie trunk come out and go
tonight we're going to talk about the
album
rocks by aerosmith and these five just
tell stories about that [ __ ] album
you know yeah there's hours of countless
of this [ __ ] you know we love stories as
americans we do and i think um
when i was
19 i mean i told you the story already
when i was 19
this guy goes uh
i got a last minute scholarship to
college and part of the deal was
teaching in between uh
hold on one sec
can't relapse on your podcast
they uh
they said we're gonna have this guy tell
a story
i'm 19. i'd never heard of a storyteller
before i mean i know what stories were
but like a guy who called himself a
storyteller like what the [ __ ] who does
that
this old guy's like
60 ambles out he's old then not so old
now and uh
he goes hey my name's i think his name i
know his first name was due i think it
might have been joe liebman or joe
lieberman he goes i'm a storyteller and
i'm like what i'm 19. you know i know
everything
and he goes i'm going to tell you the
story
it's a room full of 19 year olds he goes
i'm going to tell you the story of the
telltale heart
and i go
the [ __ ] edgar allen posting
he goes yeah i go you can read it out of
a book he goes will you sit down and i'm
going to tell you this story so i go
okay and i'm looking around everybody
like the [ __ ] is this guy going to do he
starts telling the story
the whole thing you know the guy's got
the body the detectives are there at the
kitchen table he's got the body buried
under the floors he's freaking out he
thinks they know and [ __ ] hear the
heart beating and then finally he just
screams at this the cops at the end if i
did it i did it right when he screams
everyone including me jumped
and i thought this [ __ ] guy got me
how did he get me how the [ __ ] did this
guy get me
so he goes alright i'm gonna next class
is coming in and so i we're all leaving
and i go are you going to tell the next
class the same story he goes yeah i go
can i stay and he goes absolutely so
this time
i watched the audience
as he tell the story and everyone arms
crossed legs crossed pouty
guys elbowing their friends this [ __ ]
jackass right and then the arms uncross
the legs on cross the posture starts to
slouch then they're leaning in
[ __ ] hands on their faces wrapped
attention anxiety they couldn't [ __ ]
believe it he screamed again everyone
[ __ ] jumped he got him back to back
story was about 20 minutes long i
couldn't [ __ ] believe it was a
pivotal moment
to answer you like when did i know when
did i
i watched a guy do it
it's the difference between stephen
tyler coming and telling a story and a
professional it's the guy that can make
people at work laugh and the comedian
like to be a real legit storyteller i've
studied
preachers pimps cops for c marines for
command presence
theater second city
acting classes voice classes all of that
stuff the nuance watch the greats how to
create a narrative that blasts right
through you grabs you by the [ __ ]
heart and drags you towards me that's
what i want to do that's what that's the
best that i'm searching for we got some
north hollywood [ __ ] going out on the
corner [ __ ] yeah
it's interesting because you guys were
talking about podcasts earlier and i
firmly believe that
similar to something that we've talked
about with uh comedy before is that
there's gonna be different kinds of
podcasts there's going to be podcasts of
stories there's podcasts with improv and
it's something similar what you're going
through like
everyone like this all comedy in this in
that comedy but you have 20 years of
experience
telling
like keeping people's interest now that
you're going to maybe not only funny
stories you're still going to be
years ahead of like an author who wants
to read their books exactly yeah yeah so
i'm trying to fold that in and see what
that looks like and the first because i
just finished a book right so october
1st i handed in my memoir right it took
me longer than i care to write but i had
all those other things going on and now
i'm in the process of rewriting that
that's all i'm doing i have two pitches
and if those go that'll be great but all
i'm focusing on is this memoir so i'm
taking all the 20 years 20 years of
stand up acting gigs
improv stuff all of it and i hopefully
this book gets published in 2017 and
then i tour the book in theaters and i
will perform the stories that are in the
[ __ ] book you get to come see him
live you walk out into the lobby you can
get a copy take a picture with you get
the book discounted
i'm gonna do all of it i'm working with
the editor and the agent right now she
actually just emailed me the first round
of notes are coming out on the 21st
she's going to mail them to chicago
because i'm going to be in chicago the
19th through the 29th
and that's it that's all i'm focusing on
is this [ __ ] book to make
the best that i can my personal best
this book put it out then tour that book
now will you we'll be in stores or do
you
are you playing on the e-book in it what
is your strategy uh she's fairly
confident i have a literary agent in new
york that um read the first draft she's
like i'm in she used to be an editor
she's gonna she's
we're gonna do the book in thirds so the
notes on the first third are coming out
the 21st should probably take me about a
month to turn around so three months
from now
early 2017
should have a draft ready to send out to
publishers and set up and then whatever
their time frame is but she's very
confident that she could set it up
somewhere she's happy with the way that
it was written
and um i would
love that's a dream come true man to
walk into a bookstore
and see a book
if i let all this go of what i really
really wanted since i was a kid was to
write right i've always been writing and
i love sometimes i get to perform what i
wrote other times people just get to
read it i send it out but that to me was
been the dream to be a published author
since i was like in third grade writing
stories we used we had a great hustle me
and this kid mike kona
we would get copy paper from the office
at the school and we would do comic
books and write but include the kids in
the school and the teachers would sell
them for a quarter but because we
included them we sold more because they
wanted to see what they were up to that
week it was a great great idea
more kids should be doing that now yeah
schools that's the way to get [ __ ]
real writing and [ __ ] yeah
experience nah i believe in
you gotta shut the door before another
one opens and a lot of people
don't believe that concept you know
listen man as as [ __ ] up as this
sounds
i have an out for this stand-up game you
know i have an out when
i want to really start being around my
child absolutely no i could do what i
want i got two years till
she has to be in the first grade but i
have two years to make a decision i
would still continue to do the podcast
i'd still continue to write i try to get
myself like a magazine job maybe writing
articles or something piece work yeah i
really don't give a [ __ ]
it's just that
uh the stand-up game for me takes a lot
of my [ __ ] time that's it and but
this is the game i chose yeah and this
is the level i've gotten to how i don't
have no [ __ ] idea it just
i kept working on it and believing in it
and um
i'm gonna play this hand out but there's
an out you know i'd love to beat don
rickles at 90. he's playing [ __ ]
candy club yeah canyon club you know but
i need a [ __ ] out there's got to be
an out to make me happy yeah
i've always had a dream of living in a
[ __ ] regular
little redneck community maybe getting a
[ __ ] job at a truck store with good
old boys and if i sell four months four
trucks a month i make my nut you know i
don't need to kill myself you know there
was a time when
i understood the value of killing
yourself for what you believe in
your home and stuff i don't believe in
those values anymore i don't have them
i've switched them to more of a family
type thing you know where
i'd rather take that energy and spend it
with my family
my firm belief when i got married was
that
the man went out and worked [ __ ] 14
hour days and we put away money and we
had all this and we supplied a
household and [ __ ] like that and you did
that till
you [ __ ] yeah yeah i tell you when
i tell you when to do that because i
could see myself
doing that as a young married guy and
that's why that relationship didn't work
that on top of a lot of other things
but now when it's time to work for me
it's time to work thursday morning comes
along [ __ ] you and the horse you rode up
on yeah i'm on a [ __ ] plane this is
what i enjoy on the way out my wife we
got the house the car you know
my wife doesn't have to work which means
more in the world to me
than anything
both you know this time right now where
the baby's at yeah if i didn't have a
child my wife would be working more than
[ __ ] me i'd whip that mule to because
them [ __ ] could work jack
you know but no no no no and i tell her
all the time you know i just had an
interesting thing when i first moved up
here and my wife you know when you have
a child you obtain different friends
and they're out of their [ __ ] mind up
here you know what i'm saying the
friends you meet in this area here we're
with parents
parents are totally out of their mind we
became friends with them chit-chatted
dinner with the children the children
played
she's uh very nice he's really cool he's
one of us
she's very nice but i don't think she
knows how crazy this white boy is i mean
he's out of his [ __ ] mind he came to
one of my shows in new york and hooked
up with my buddies and they disappear
for an hour they went to get a package
i'm like he does packages i got this guy
that was the nicest white dude in
america
anyway you know he's an actor like a
theater actor and
uh small roles and but a lot of
voiceovers he's part of that voiceover
so we were talking one day like after we
knew him for two years in austin they're
like did we tell you we're moving back
to new york
what are you talking about
and they're like yeah we're moving back
to new york and the careers for him are
better in new york and i'm listening to
all this and i'm looking at their lives
here they're at the park every day and
yeah yeah she flies on the weekends
she's a photographer gotcha like a
well-known wedding photographer like
loot
oh there's a lot of money yeah like loot
like you want to go to hawaii like they
don't even give a [ __ ] when she throws
them her number
she does two of those amount and they
can live like doctors
and now
we just got a note they're coming back
you know and i'm like my wife was like
what do you think about that i got that
do you think i'm [ __ ] surprised
hey do you think i'm [ __ ] surprised i
was born i'm [ __ ] new you when you
look at me you're like that dude from
new york i can't look like any new york
israel or some gorilla farm [ __ ] let
them on the loose when you look at me
there's only three places i can [ __ ]
be from okay i love new york city am i
lonely to hang out with my [ __ ]
friends at night [ __ ] yeah by now it's
leeway got shot twice
twice he would've got shot once in the
show the one in the leg one for ordering
something bad at a restaurant because my
buddies don't accept that [ __ ] we don't
know all the shitty food at restaurants
and two for aspirin for ranch
sauce
my friend my buddies would have shot him
in the [ __ ] shoulder already right
now
like don't bring this guy no more he
can't you know
uh
there's a lot of things i miss about new
york city i'm lonely at times i can do a
lot more stand up at night yeah
but i go to myself
that's a hard life compared to what i'm
doing out here we got the podcast
we don't have to drive in traffic i was
in edgewater that's where they live in
edgewater i was in edgewater one night
you know when you opened your curtains
at the hotel like i opened the curtains
oh
i looked outside at 6 15
the traffic didn't move
i [ __ ] opened my thing rolled the
joint licked it i was just watching the
traffic i was like when you do like let
me roll three joints of the night it's a
little early but i'm entertained by this
trip i can't imagine living here
i told my wife i got an audition
okay
i got an audition i had to be in the
city the next day let's pretend it was a
10 for the uber yeah but it's 18 for
both ways to go over in the [ __ ]
ferry okay that's nine each way joey
could you get a little cheaper yeah
maybe five for the bus okay so maybe ten
when i got to the city again i owe but
it was a 20 there and another 20 to go
from caa to the [ __ ] ferry back
so what you're telling me is i dropped
[ __ ] 70 and that was without any
nourishment or a newspaper i lied i got
a hot dog and a [ __ ] whatever and now
you're a c-note out the door you're in
new york city you're dropping all
[ __ ] day yeah i ain't saying nothing
to you lee am i cheating with you i love
you lee do i am i spontaneously do we
give a [ __ ] do we have a budget league
do we do we even live like that do we
say those words no there's days i don't
have cash for five [ __ ] days because
you use a stupid atm card where do we go
7-eleven
i'm gonna do [ __ ] this is i go home and
look at my account and go uh joey you
got to go out there and spend something
and then i thought it's the weed store
i'll take 100 cash advance for weed but
besides that i went to new york and i
looked at the cash i spent in three days
in new york and i don't do deck guys you
know me i eat cuban food at the wrong
restaurant
i had chinese food at the time what was
the name of the [ __ ] chinese
chad's dragon then oh the cuban steak
jordan i went to no you said there was a
cube in chinese place yeah
but look at this did you hear that oh
yeah trust me he's about to show you he
has the full menu on his phone look at
this look at this
is popping the [ __ ] around
if you want to [ __ ] around
number next to it go hang out with your
buddies if you want to [ __ ] around but
look at this just and this i show this
to you because again i don't want you to
say [ __ ]
joey's [ __ ] crazy doggy
he don't do dick he don't uh
and while you're looking for it look at
this
two cuban sandwiches steak two cuban
steak sandwiches a milkshake
a milkshake what kind of milkshake a
papaya mame what and two cuban steak
sandwiches a milkshake and two [ __ ]
diet sodas
2150 okay
you know you look at this and you go out
here it's 21. look at the cuban steak
sandwich with they cooked the fries with
the [ __ ] beef that's been there
with some [ __ ] hot sauce you have no
idea who you're [ __ ] with you know
what i'm saying oh look at the roll too
look at the roll look at this here oh no
look at this look at this [ __ ] here this
is enough look at this [ __ ] what is
this
oh that's the steak and eggs [ __ ]
original joes
most people post these on instagram
shout out to i just went to los balconer
is the place i told you about that
peruvian spot on vine and de la prince
oh your [ __ ] right down the
block from gotham perfect when they got
a [ __ ] look at the
got a stromboli's
[ __ ] stromboli because they hit him
in the oven for about five minutes yeah
god melt that baby
i even got this [ __ ] pepperoni
roll and i took a bite out of the long
distance embarrassing calzone with the
little yeah
the [ __ ] thing that i don't know i
just give it up i'm not gonna get it
here so i just live my life
and i accept it that's the right [ __ ] it
is what's the what well that's the rub
you're out here you gotta you know you
pick your poisons out here but you're
not it's never ever ever ever ever going
to be back home and then you can't go
back like i go back now it's a different
city it's a different city i can't i
would go to like i told my mom like oh
listen i could have got a wild bug in my
ass came back
blue smoke up your ass cost a bunch of
money carried these cats across the
[ __ ] country in a car shivering the
whole [ __ ] time to move to new york
association fees traffic yeah you know i
live here to avoid all that yeah i
surround my day to avoid all this we
also live in a place where
people shat on for many years in la the
valley oh you live in the valley the
valley now everyone's moving to the
[ __ ] valley the only way to go i got
everything i need up here
shout outs i got everything i [ __ ]
need yeah bobby and crystal down there
we're gonna see them in houston next
week lee's coming down
to the [ __ ] coming getting festival
on the 18th
chad reese
jesse shaw geno robles david kirkpatrick
lee james amy cleans up nicely and my
main lover martha how's that one for you
and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
no i love uh
i like people
i talked in and every once in their life
they cut it's called cutting the fat out
of your life and people never accept it
but you have to do it for the right
reasons you have to know when to close
that door and you have to know when to
be honest with yourself you know someone
from new york is calling right now i
mean i figure however
i figure i figure how the [ __ ] people uh
when they go home and go you know what
this acting's been enough for me i've
had a great time
i'm moving back to iowa i'm gonna take
all my dad's butchery i'm gonna live
like a human [ __ ] being
and it's time to that i have that dream
yeah i just don't have a dad with a
butchery you know
you know business
i don't have a grandmother flower shop
that's dying to sell it you know some
[ __ ] some little bum town there's a
small community and everybody knows
everybody you know when i went to
chicago one thing i did notice about
rosemont and the community design there
is that there's a sort of respect people
know each other i mean we went to get
the steak sandwich what was the name the
first day with josh yeah that's right
he went down twice yeah else beef's good
house beef is good yeah you know it's so
weird even the people there were very
nice and lisa he lost his phone and
somebody turned it in
that his friend and [ __ ] friends
vegas they threw him out of the hotel he
was like at least can you put the video
on this you stole my phone [ __ ] now you
know
it's just it's a stand-up town it's it's
uh i mean i miss it i miss it a lot i'm
happy for the the the city because the
cubs won oh my god i mean it's just
[ __ ] great oh my [ __ ] god
today the black pitcher
and the manager would have got
assassinated the manager with the
glasses on like that here i could
already see red little dots on him
towards the end of the game he had a
sniper up there and [ __ ] on one of
the cross the street rooms that was
prepared he already got the call from
the janano brothers the two escobars
yeah as soon as they lose shoot that
[ __ ] right in the eyeball like
the guy in the godfather when he put his
glasses on yeah
he looked goofy as [ __ ] with those
glasses on he pulled that dude and then
put the big black dude out and the black
dude knew his fate too did you see him
oh yeah he stopped trying man he was
done smile champion was shot he didn't
smile
till they took the lead until then he
was sitting that thing going who do i
leave my car stereo too and [ __ ] i spent
30 g's on that [ __ ] you ain't
just gonna shoot he knew they were gonna
put him in the room with the kid who
made the catch
that kid disappeared they got him in a
room somewhere they're still smacking
them today they finally let him go and
they gave water in the sandwich they go
listen it's going to be all right
we're just kidding
what's the how long ago was that
which one when the kids apartment oh
bartman yeah oh that was 2002 i think
four four 2004. there's some crazy guy
in chicago got him in a basement right
now
and every day during training season he
kicks them and every time the cubs lose
he just kicks them and [ __ ] and one last
night that this morning the guy came
down with like eggs and breakfast and
flowers the kids like was that korean
movie where the guy was locked in the
room for [ __ ] 30 years remember that
and josh brolin just did the remake with
spike lee directing that was it they had
to lock that white kid kicked him every
day and today was his day today was his
lucky day guess what the cubs won what
year is it
that he's like a vietnam vet rambo saved
his beard down it was yeah i think i was
like what year is it
1985. and the guy just looks around the
room and she brian then he opens the
door in the sheriff's outfit my god oh
my god that poor kid that poor [ __ ] do
you think there's a chance he still
lives in chicago i think no he had to
move to europe did he really yeah they
published his uh they published his work
address and home address in both papers
and they had to have uh police cars in
front of us
that was [ __ ] crazy i know yeah that
is crazy that kid deserved every kick
every punch
he was about to get that point they had
to cover him in coach there's youtube
footage of them
getting them out of wrigley and
knuckleheaded second from the left on
the evolutionary chart chicagoans are
like is that the [ __ ] guy is that the
guy and they're trying to get to him and
undercover cops are like whacking these
drunk [ __ ] to get him off
oh my god yeah people take their sports
series oh man crazy if they would have
lost last night after they had the lead
because i called leo you know this is
still a grand slam away yeah and on some
pop i don't want something pop and i go
oh no
yeah it sticks the [ __ ] up and then they
really throw that juice off into the
[ __ ] scab they threw a rain delay at
you that's the kiss of death right there
that is because yeah that's the kiss of
death because the game has to shut off
at 1am
but if there's a rain delay
they will substitute that time so the
game could go too if they rained late
game shut off at one you do know that
because one o'clock chicago time is 2
a.m and [ __ ] the east coast yeah
i know this because when i was a child
there was a [ __ ] game that went on
until [ __ ] and 92 innings started at
7 30 and at one in the [ __ ] morning
they're still playing out there and they
had to cancel the game and it opens up
the next day as a tie
so it becomes a double header
i wonder what they would do it like they
would have to just play the game seven
of the world series i don't think they
that'd be in crazy if they did that if
it wasn't for that rain delay
i think the cubs would have lost because
the momentum was so heavy on the
cleveland side
so heavy that they had shut the cubs
down top of the ninth going into the
bottom of the ninth cleveland was ready
ready to get someone on base ready to
score
and that rain delay just shut everything
down er cleveland was
hot ready to win the [ __ ] world
series shut down pause button hayward
rallies everybody calls a meeting in the
middle of the rain delay hayward's been
struggling the entire series and made
his salary earned his spot on that team
by giving everyone a motivational rally
speech during the delay
that calmed everybody down and shifted
the momentum and i think it was three up
three down or they might have had
somebody on first and the bottom of the
ninth and then the cubs went on the tear
top of the 10th and cleveland never
caught up but if it wasn't for that rain
delay i really believe the cubs would
have lost
what do you what were you thinking when
they tied it because i come from boston
i still remember oh same thing you felt
i still remember well here's the thing i
was because joey told me that you were
coming on and i was thinking about what
i went through in o4 and i was i was
excited i was
i think was like a freshman in high
school
and it was like the big cowboy up thing
it was it was huge
but i'm i don't want to say i'm jealous
but i was only
17 something like that
i can't imagine the the euphoria
of like a grandparent like i saw like
i've been watching videos all day of
like grandpa seeing and i saw this guy
went and drove to indiana to listen to
it with his father's gravesite yeah and
i was just like that
i almost feel like i got gypped out of
it a little bit because i had only
really been like interested in the red
sox
what maybe 10 years
yeah like how long could i really be
involved in it yeah so like everyone
else was excited i went to the parade i
wore my parade shirt yesterday in
support of the cubs from 04
but i can't imagine being your age or 80
or whatever and
my age are 80 well
just
there's obviously a lot in between yeah
like it means a lot because i watch the
cub lose a lot
and it's the
i think for a long time before the
ricketts bought the cubs and hired theo
epstein from you know the tournament
it's unbelievable that guy's never gonna
i mean
to bring both boston and the cubs in the
world series champions is incredible
managerial and leadership skills
but i think like
if you have a last place team or a team
that's always struggling and you're
still selling out the jerseys and you
still sell out every game there's very
little motivation to win the the type of
of cutting edge
biting
you know really dominant wanting to win
that you need like not that you need
struggle but you know that that really
like deep deep deep down within you
desire to win it's very difficult to
have that when you're they're not
spending the money which they did they
brought up their farm system which they
did
why would you do that if you're getting
paid and you're losing
the the management isn't going to do
anything about that when ricketts bought
the team i think the whole idea was he
was a fan of cubs baseball
lived across the street from the stadium
loved the team and loved to win
it brought theo epstein on to create a
culture of winning and that's what you
need not lovable losers that was that
was the moniker of the team
lovable losers
that was i mean how the [ __ ] are you
gonna win until you completely change
that mindset and i think that's what
they did starting with their aaa system
and bringing up and nurturing winners
it's fascinating i mean i'm fascinated
with that you know you said you made
some mistakes in your 20s 30s a little
bit in your 40s
me too
i'm fascinated with it i made a mistake
yesterday by not betting [ __ ] chicago
that's the mistake i made right there we
made mistakes not bad it was like 500 to
100 200 just to watch the [ __ ] game
yeah it's amazingly that i wouldn't i
i checked and i said one of the games
this week and they said game six is
tuesday i don't know what day it was
maybe sunday somebody asked me or monday
and i said when is the
game seven thursdays and they go no
wednesday i go done
like in my mind i'm done yeah done when
they won tuesday wednesday i walked
around all day
and i got to be honest with you
[ __ ] man
uh
i just thought about being 10 and going
to see
the mets play the reds and when pete
rose beat up butter harris and i thought
about
being younger than that and my mom you
know i was six when the mets won the
championship in new york and you know
just walked jumping up and down with my
mom and i thought about those memories i
thought about when pittsburgh one yeah i
thought about one big red machine one of
the worst
world series of my life that to this day
i i preach it
the cincinnati reds against the boston
red sox to me
a great series for many reasons you know
for colton fisk hitting the home run for
just the excitement when it you know
staying up and my mom called me going
you gotta go to bed at ten [ __ ] you and
hanging up on and [ __ ] stand up until
midnight to watch the reds and johnny
bench and just to rose man and rose just
to have that this week in baseball on
saturday mornings with johnny bench
remember that yes a little before your
time lady but oh my god just uh the the
feeling of of being a kid and when that
when they showed the camera of the guy
with his son last night i had a nervous
breakdown i'm like because that easily
remember that forever that little kid oh
my god he's gonna remember that until
his 62 he takes his son
to see them win again hopefully in the
next hundred and eight [ __ ] years
over don't take you know the honesty
about both those two teams and i hate
talking a lot of sports on the show but
they didn't demand their respect today
is that they're both great teams like
the guys that last night they're both
going to be there for the next three or
four years
played like savages and they're young
that little young puerto rican kid oh my
god
yeah bomb the left
and i love their their manager terry
francona yeah it's i haven't watched
baseball in a while
it's just i even called joey called it
like the fourth inning i said i was
bored
and
i don't know what if i don't have a team
in the in the race i kind of check out
but aft i went i went and i made dinner
and i came back i like the sixth inning
and i started watching and they showed
the clip the clip that got me was when
dave ross and anthony rizzo were talking
and anthony rizzo was like i can't
control my emotions yeah yeah yeah and i
was like yeah like you're what like 21
and then i just they said he he beat
cancer and now he's like an mvp and now
he he can't control his emotions and
like that's like that's when i checked
in in like the sixth inning yeah because
then that's like the best time to go
watch baseball they suck you in and
listen man great story you think i was
following chicago in june you want me to
tell you that i knew chicago was going
to win in june do you want me to tell it
i thought cleveland was the team in june
i wish i got those psychic powers but no
i wasn't cheering for a [ __ ] team
like that yeah i was cheering for what i
was watching for america i was cheering
for [ __ ] because that's what i grew
up on that was the bible october is
baseball bible i don't give a [ __ ] what
plans you got there was no way i was
doing a podcast last night there was no
way just out of respect to me like today
i'll do a podcast on christmas while
they're stabbing jesus while jesus is
coming out of the womb before i do a
[ __ ] podcast on [ __ ] during the
world series
i don't give a [ __ ] about the
basketball i really don't give a [ __ ]
about football because of the halftime
show baseball they've kept it pure
there's no halftime show there wasn't a
section of celebrities
you know beside bill murray and i accept
that [ __ ] because he's been
there since day one yeah yeah as goofy
as he is with his jacket that's what it
does to people yeah this is your team
and i sit here every [ __ ] week and i
get mad at lee that i don't have a team
like i didn't have stock on the team
take the cups take the cups get into the
cabinets cubs now because now they're
gonna look at me and go you [ __ ] no
no no yeah that's the city you just did
your special there that's how beautiful
the city is man you know like take the
team i wish i could be a fan of the
dodgers there's something about the
dodgers that bother me completely
i like them i like watching them i watch
games at night if i'm home for an hour i
watch three innings of a dodger game
you know i wish i had a team so i could
have a part of that in my life you know
you don't follow the meds
because that's the thing i lose respect
for people when they tell me they switch
teams well yeah me too you can't you
should why just give it a chance man you
know what happened i know what teams to
be a fan you know what happened to me
when i was a fan
i didn't like how involved
and how personal i took [ __ ]
i can't deal with no yeah no i can't
believe how involved and how personal
i took [ __ ] i don't like that because at
the end of the day it's a [ __ ] sports
team why am i crying why am i throwing
[ __ ] why am i kicking tvs
i had one jersey why is the dog not
breathing yeah i had one jersey in my
life i had a jersey of the sixers
in 1976 when julius irving played i s i
i wouldn't jersey be worth about three
grand right now
i wouldn't take it out of the house i
wouldn't sweat on it i would just put it
on when i was home especially i would
watch it with a laker game when i was
watching the sixth game by myself
i'd watch this [ __ ] thing
and we had this [ __ ] kid that lived
right behind me it was just his [ __ ]
birthday a couple months ago somebody
called me and they said we'd like you to
fly out and do [ __ ] comedy for this
googooches birthday jimmy bianco i said
what jimmy bianco are you talking about
the one that lived on charles court they
go yeah tell that [ __ ] i never
want to see that [ __ ] again we
were kids he was half [ __ ] he got
hit in the head with a [ __ ] brick or
something he'd walk around and give
predictions and sometimes people would
punch him like he was one of those guys
he had a long hand a beard and sometimes
people would punch him in the head i i
wasn't a bully [ __ ] two golden coins
like people would punch him and [ __ ]
like jimmy get the [ __ ] out of here you
know
and one day i kind of became friends
with jimmy he would talk i would shoot
hoops in my backyard he'd come to his
fence and i gave him some love i mean
who the [ __ ] am i to turn down somebody
and i talked to him about this or that
but he was really like for a nerd
he was very sports oriented and somebody
told me that when you make a bet talk to
jerry bianco he's got always reading the
stats and she's got supernatural powers
and [ __ ] so i played him for a couple
times jimmy what do you got tonight he
was oh oh yes yes yes tonight the sixers
are giving sex
you had let me just look at the paper
and he would [ __ ] win this went on
for like [ __ ] a year this [ __ ]
longhead hippie was like 21-1 and here i
am sitting here [ __ ] stealing bikes
with valentine and robbing my stepfather
i could have been making a myth with
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
julius irving joins the [ __ ] sixers
and guess what he becomes a sixer fan so
me and him talk sixers all the time he
knows stats he knows body types he knows
biorhythms i mean he's hit me from every
direction
[ __ ] uh
he tells me one day the sixers are in
the finals against the portland
trailblazers and he's telling me the
sixers and six
sixers and six
and he like i was done i went upstairs i
took every dollar i could i robbed my
stepfather i took
pennies from santa lazaro
i took quarters i sold everything i
could and i put a grand fortune
like
750 dollars
when i'm in the seventh grade on the
[ __ ] sixes because jimmy bianco plus
i had a deal i was gonna bump another
yardstick from my mom and throw that on
game six
this [ __ ]
six has come out the box jack [ __ ]
two-and-oh sweeping this [ __ ]
i'm over there about to suck jimmy
bianco's dick and [ __ ] cuz jimmy bianco
[ __ ] no scores this guy's [ __ ]
money do you know they lost in game six
to this day i have not talked to joey
bianco because it wasn't just a bet it
was my team yeah yeah like he ruined it
for me like he ruined my team since
seventh grade you haven't said hello
[ __ ] that bum
and my mother was furious because i gave
some of the info to my mom
she bought 10 g's she was like oh no
that [ __ ] had to lay on the
fence with his long hippie hair and [ __ ]
wait wait wait you gave your mom betting
advice in seventh grade oh yeah i told
her the psychic told me [ __ ] the sex
is in
and oh my mother you just tell that
story at his birthday party and then go
so [ __ ] you and your mom
yeah all my mother needed was a push to
gamble do you understand me i came from
a gambling house
cubans are gambling people so when i
told them i remember like six people bet
that we were all i never watched
basketball before i had eight cubans in
my house watching basketball cheering
for these you're jumping up and down for
[ __ ] uh people saying little things
i'm like a 13 year old your friend's a
[ __ ] bum he's going to lose at that
people
don't even know how to get when you're
[ __ ] back to the game you believe
them
i was [ __ ] furious i never got over
jimmy bianco and [ __ ]
till this day i wouldn't even [ __ ]
just sixes and six i was so [ __ ]
excited i would i ripped that [ __ ]
sixer jersey too
it would have been nice to make five
prop bets to bet the cubs to win over
the last say four years a grand every
year because it had to be fifteen
sixteen to one lose four grand come in
at fifteen twenty thousand
that's the bet that i regret not making
you know because i saw you all the time
on the flight in vegas i go for every
ufc fight that's there
and just take a prop at like two years
from now what are the odds you know tell
ask the bookmaker what are the odds of
the cubs are gonna go to the world
series next year just bet three years
out straight g each year you're gonna
get paid
doesn't every [ __ ] gambler say that
if you get hit by a [ __ ] car the
third year you ain't getting [ __ ] all
right and your wife forgot about putting
the batteries
with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] window
i'm really happy for the city of chicago
they uh yeah you know bob lalink is his
dad they're all chicago cup friends it's
crazy i think the white dogs fans i
think that white sox fans you got to be
careful with chicago people because if
you get some [ __ ] roughnecks from the
south side they take that white sox
seriously
he started [ __ ] yelling at everybody
yeah south side chicago people that
voodoo didn't work you know what i'm
saying they cut chicken heads i was
gonna ask they stabbed the goat is that
a maluk area that's a maluk area they
put the maluka on [ __ ]
on chicago and they still want not
listen man like i said for me
the basketball went downhill
you know football the super bowl is a
great thing i just don't like what
they've done to it over the years and
whose shows yeah i don't like that they
take over a city and [ __ ] like that yeah
but listen when we when we did the
the special in rosemont
the planes were backed up that day
october 4th october 13th
they canceled the flight plus the planes
were delayed i don't know if you [ __ ]
know this you could get to chicago
that's the least proud of your problems
if somebody ever comes to you and says
you gotta go to chicago
no worries there's 92 flights a day yeah
to chicago every airline will drop you
off even people's even the spirit will
put you in a [ __ ] anti-dump bag and
dump you over [ __ ] o'hara and you
land on a trampoline and [ __ ] for fat
people
you could always get to chicago how busy
was that chicago wing that day our
friend had a one o'clock flight didn't
get into la in into chicago till 10. why
because they were delayed all day the
plane there was no first class tickets
no upgrades no nothing i asked the owner
of the club one of the owners though
with a manager at roosevelt i said man
tickets were expensive
and there was a nightmare getting in she
goes my friends having the same problem
she goes the problem is
whenever chicago goes into the pl in
these playoffs people fly in just to be
here yeah yeah when i heard just to be
in the city when i heard that it was
like
it makes sense i would have [ __ ] fly
i totally to stay i almost did right now
you could have been telling your friends
you saw the cubs the year they won the
champion see what i'm saying
you [ __ ] it up again another mission
another mission you [ __ ] up with look
at your blue shirt on you have your
chicago cub shirt on today you gotta
have it on like i was that's that's all
i was thinking about last night i was
like i have to go see the red sox like
at some point in my life when they're in
the world series and they could
like i want to be out of game seven at a
game yeah whenever they have a chance to
win
but it's [ __ ] up that you said that
the sticks are lost
i don't remember like i vaguely remember
watching the red sox win but i remember
vividly the year before
when tim wakefield got a homer off of
him by aaron boone like when he when
like they like the year before 03 they
were playing the yankees and the yankees
won in like game seven in new york aaron
boone hit a home run off of tim
wakefield and i just remember i was
sitting on the floor of my mother's
bedroom and just like that walk back to
my bedroom i that's that's something
[ __ ] up about me remember
the patriots losing to the giants with
the stupid helmet catch i remember but i
don't really remember the good stuff i
just remember being happy and excited
all the losses i remember like vividly
yeah it's [ __ ] weird
that that helmet catch was terrible you
were [ __ ] whacking through this guy
you don't know you don't like remember
like obviously
yeah [ __ ] yeah i remember every
i still remember sitting there watching
the mets
play baltimore orioles when they beat
him in the world series i think it was
baltimore i still remember coming home i
stormed them pittsburgh pirates
in the world series with candelaria and
willie star jill yeah we are family
they're doing blow and shooting steroids
and [ __ ] who's the guy that took the
acid
oh yeah yeah doc boone doc willis jack
willis yeah yeah
just uh you remember all that stuff from
baseball you know it's a and like i said
it's a shame that
i don't have like a blanket with a team
on it or you know i don't have that no
more like i don't have any stock in the
team you know if i like a team i'll
watch it but i'm the type of guy that's
too embarrassed to go get a hat because
then people go
and it's true you're a [ __ ] you just
jump on the bandwagon and [ __ ]
brother uh congratulations on bringing
the podcast back thank you i'm happy you
came in today and visited us yeah thanks
for having me guys yeah no we wanted to
[ __ ] talk to you i wanted somebody
from chicago in here today just to talk
about whether they want a loss just yeah
yeah the reaction and see what it was
like i know you're i called you right
away i've been thinking about everybody
from chicago the last week and going i
wonder what the [ __ ] they're thinking
you know it's uh
i can't imagine that city today i can't
imagine what that city's gonna be like
this weekend because it's not gonna stop
no are you going to fly back for the
parade you should i mean i don't know
what if it you can no no you don't know
why the parade's important killers don't
go to parade yes you do
that's what happens like you they're
going to parade the popcorn and the
[ __ ] hot dog with ketchup on it or
some [ __ ] ketchup you don't forget you
yeah
no i know i don't yes i put mustard i
always spell it on my shirt and so i
can't put anything on it so but no i not
and not every year but after 108 years
can you imagine there's going to be a
million people oh million pickpockets
what the [ __ ] the matter with you
that's the people who really believe the
hype
you never we don't go to parades all
right church people don't go to parades
number one i want to
talk to you about something important
let me tell you what's important right
now in your life for the holidays a
[ __ ] bidet you know why because
bidets are back you're like joey you've
been here talking about bidets what the
[ __ ] are you talking about they're
devices that spray your muffler clean
with water you understand me i grew up
with a bidet in my house tremendous
now thanks to tushy sleek bidet that
clips onto your existing toilet that's
right it clips onto the existing toilet
and sprays your butt completely
solid clean with fresh water to get your
muffler clean
so you're not sitting on bacteria
causing hemorrhoids yeast infections and
just plain old rotten ass you understand
me you've had rotten ass and you sit
queer and it blows out of the back of
your belt down tight
also the whole room smells like rotten
ass trust me it's happened to me not
since i've had the hello tushy [ __ ]
bidets
and the days are better for the
environment no paper more more trees
capiche and it only takes a pint of
water to wash your little muffler okay
tushy stands behind that product this
ain't no [ __ ] okie doke product if it
can handle uncle joey's [ __ ] and my
[ __ ] weight it can handle your skinny
little muffler right and they've got a
60 day
guarantee burst they got towels coming
out that you put right next to you and
you wipe your little muffler spotless
and let me tell you something it don't
stop there with your muffler why be a
pig if you're a woman dip that monkey in
that [ __ ] water revitalize that
[ __ ] if you're a man listen when
i tushy my muffler i just don't push in
my muffler i wipe the sides i clean out
the nuts behind that flat that's where
the mildew develops and i pull the skin
back on the turtleneck to get my helmet
washing clean why walk around with a
clean ass and a stinky dick or vice
versa you understand me go to
hellotushy.com right now i'm going to
give you 10 off on this ducking stuffing
stocking stuffer okay because number one
anybody can give you a [ __ ] tie or a
wrist watch or a knife you give somebody
a [ __ ] portable bidet in their
stocking and see what happens who's the
most popular [ __ ] man at that party
from now on but don't believe me go to
hello tushy hello with a capital h
tushy.com right now slash church you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna give
you a 10 off your order okay tushy's
going to take good care of you they got
a 60-day money-back guarantee and
they're a great company and they're
great to deal with and i'm telling you
this firsthand this is the christmas
gift you want to send to your [ __ ]
friend you know that fat [ __ ] uncle
you got that always farts at
thanksgiving he needs his ass washed you
know your grandmother she's really sweet
but you can tell she hasn't washed that
[ __ ] in eight months she needs that
[ __ ] hello tushy you know a little
kid that sits next to you you know he's
got rotten ass he hasn't wiped his ass
since day one
give him hello does she go to
hellotushy.com
right now slash church get ten percent
off now you want healthy [ __ ]
i mean why wash your ass with hello
tushy if you're not taking healthy shits
that's why you got to go to holland on
it.com right now they got a great
selection of supplements from the from
the hemp chocolate protein to the
vanilla acai these [ __ ] will
take care of you aubrey searches the
globe looking for quality ingredients
that will benefit you to the [ __ ]
hundred percent max whether it's the
alpha brand when you've got 100
guaranteed money back on or whether it's
the new mood or the hemp four or the
hemp force protein or the or the shroom
tech listen i live on shroom tech when i
fly immune i get sick from time to time
but don't go over the border but don't
believe me go to honor.com right now
look at the great selection of
supplements they got you want something
give it a try start with the hemp
protein chocolate cocoa it's going to
blow your mind go to honor.com and press
church boom c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 percent off your first order
delivered to your [ __ ] cousin let me
talk to you people buy something from
the heart let me hit the cecil page
there let me talk to you [ __ ]
from the heart right now it's november
2nd it's november third second who the
[ __ ] knows all right he's dropping
bottles this [ __ ] mook over here
cecil is a new affiliate of nbc okay
i can blow smoke up your ass and give
you speeches or whatnot cesaro's a new
affiliate of nbc they're gonna be
carrying [ __ ] it's gonna be the
comedy [ __ ] channel to be a part of
i'm very fortunate that they're going to
accept my special and start earning it
december 8th what i'm going to do for
you is here's what uncle joey's doing
for you grab a [ __ ] pen right now all
right
what i'm going to do for you is
the best thing is it's 3.99 a month okay
and that's all great and dandy but i'm
what i'm going to do for you right now
is i'm going to give all my listeners a
free two month when you call use promo
code joey again
promo code joey at checkout i'm gonna
give you two free months which will
carry you over to january [ __ ] second
you know what that's gonna do you can
watch specials you can watch saturday
night lives you can watch the original
programming but you can watch uncle
joey's special over over over over over
and over again that's what i'm going to
do for you i'm going to give it to you
for free i'm not going to charge you
five bucks like everybody else i'm not
going to nothing it's coming out on ciso
if you can put it on your [ __ ] roku
and you're gonna live like a doctor so
do me a favor right now as personal as
friends i know you're sitting in your
[ __ ] cubicle grab a pen right now
grab it
you're gonna go to
cso.com right now you're gonna sign up
two months for free
with the promo code joey okay you're
gonna watch other shows like hidden in
america with jonah ray and harmonquest
and take my wife they're all great shows
but you're gonna do me a [ __ ] silence
i don't want to die money 399 a month
for two [ __ ] months you're not gonna
pay by using promo code joey all right
and that's it and that's that
[ __ ] i love you guys don't forget
will bethina there's 11 tickets left i
don't know you have to sit next to
somebody with rotten ass you don't have
a good day and then uh saturday night
i'm at the fox woods casino listen it's
ufc 205 this is between us they're gonna
play it at the [ __ ] casino we're
gonna run out of there go to a bar with
lee we're gonna get stoned and we're
gonna [ __ ] do a play-by-play on
periscope i will see you [ __ ]
at the fox woods casino houston texas
you've been asking i'm giving it to you
now i'm part of the in and out
come and take it comedy festival
november 18th 19th and 20th it's 35 days
35 hours for the day pass okay
you go down here you pay for the [ __ ]
pass you get them to see my show you get
to see todd barry you have to see
everybody else on that [ __ ] stage 35
[ __ ] bucks all right it's a festival
you're gonna go to houston you can eat
okay spooky you'll be there crystal and
jordan will be there it's gonna be a for
leo be there with [ __ ] rosa what's up
paula rosa who the [ __ ] knows anymore
you're like 20 [ __ ] anyway i love you
[ __ ] mick we're gonna be looking
forward to your podcast shoot over tweet
so i can retweet it for you absolutely
get your back on board i love you
[ __ ] stay black have a great
weekend and we'll be back sunday night
with felipe and uh silent bob we're
gonna do a whole new jamboree sunday
night i love you [ __ ] stay black
thank you
you